of all the Battleground States Florida
is really the biggest electoral prize
and for the Romney team simply a must
win
well could all that talk be a thing of
the past because the AP uh popping the
left's balloon today writing Democrats
are increasingly concerned that Florida
wants the nation's Premier swing state
now may slip away this fall and become
as emboldened Republicans capitalize on
divisive cultural issues and population
shifts and crucial contests for governor
and the U.S Senate joining me now is
Florida Senator Marco Rubio senator good
to see you tonight
um I guess you're just merely
capitalizing on divisive cultural issues
oh come on is it bigger than that in
Florida
well the people watching this broadcast
and and those that vote in the state are
the ones that decide what direction it
goes here's one of the things that's
happened among many what's happened is
that Hispanic voters that for years
we've been told they only care about
immigration this is what they care about
this is the only thing they care about
they do care about immigration and
primarily what we're seeing is they care
about illegal immigration they care
about a border that's out of control
they care about the fentanyl that's
coming across the border in essence if
you look at sort of and I'm not just
calling polling I'm anecdotally I live
in a Hispanic Community surrounded in
this and by people in this community
that I live here in Miami in are
increasingly indistinguishable from
non-hispanic working-class voters and
small business owners they care about
the exact same things they want schools
to teach not indoctrinate they want our
the laws to be enforced they don't want
criminals running loose and these are
the kinds of things that I think and and
not to mention we have a lot of people
that know that socialism and Marxism
doesn't work and they recognize it when
they see it so all these things have
combined is just one factor the other is
frankly a lot of people have moved here
because they'd hates what's happening in
New York and in California and in
Illinois and other places and they
certainly didn't move here in order to
ruin this state and make it look like
the state they came from so a
combination of these factors and some of
the national Trends you're seeing I
think are contributing to that but
ultimately I would say it's up to voters
we're going to find out here two weeks
from tomorrow night exactly how far
Florida has moved I feel very optimistic
if the people watching get out and vote
and don't take it for granted Senator
there are a lot of people right now who
are just afraid they're afraid of what's
happening to this country they're afraid
of crime they're afraid their life
savings is slipping away their 401ks and
declining in value what do you say to
them tonight about what Republicans in
the Senate if indeed Republicans retake
the Senate could do in the next few
years
well you know I share those exact
concerns it's the reason why I'm running
for re-election I think if the people
that are in charge of the house the
Senate and the White House if they
remain in power they are going to
destroy this country they're going to
destroy through a number of things so
the first thing we have to do is we are
a nation that's been blessed with energy
resources and I know you know as people
maybe get tired of hearing about it but
the truth of the matter is the cost of
energy is the fundamental underlying
basic underlying cost of everything when
that goes up everything goes up we have
depleted our strategic reserves we're
begging the Saudis to produce more oil
we're trying to Senator Iran and
Venezuela yeah I agree with you but what
are you guys going to do if you guys get
control of what's on it my concern is
that Republicans get control and then is
there a plan in place to really make
this affirmative case to the people and
move forward legislation that Joe Biden
is going to have to either agree to or
veto
well that that I'll put that into three
buckets or three directions that we need
to move at the same time number one is
we have to stop bad things from
happening crazy people from getting into
positions of power in the Senate we have
that power and so forth and I think just
the election alone brings an end to some
of that Insanity the second is we have
to make good things happen like energy
Independence like ensuring that federal
laws are not interfering with with
decisions that are being made at the
state level at the school board levels
and things of that nature we need to
pass those bills both on energy and on
things like education and the like and
crime for that matter and then challenge
the Biden Administration to veto it to
stand in the way of something that's
popular that's the second piece and the
third is accountability we have to use
our oversight role that we have to now
we should have hearings for example on
the Riots of the summer of 2020. there's
been no accountability about the summer
of 2020 who was behind it how much did
the political rhetoric lend itself to it
for example these efforts to bail people
out of jail in 2020. how many people did
that encourage to come back out and do
that all over again what about these
pro-life pregnancy centers that are
being firebombed across the country
there's been no examination into that so
there's a host of things like that that
we can hold government agencies
accountable for and that includes the
Border these guys love to come up and
testify about well the border is secure
I actually think that we have a role to
play in Congress to hold them
accountable for that so the
accountability piece the passing good
things and challenging him to sign it or
veto it and pay the consequences and the
keeping crazing people out of these
positions both on the bench and in the
bureaucracy are three key areas that we
can even without the White House we can
immediately begin to put this country in
the right direction and is the same for
the woke military policies that are
being put in place throughout our Armed
Forces same for that I think that's part
of the oversight I think you have these
hearings where you basically ask why are
we spending all of our time putting up
we shouldn't be fun videos about the
well absolutely but more than that you
need to hold these people accountable
especially the civilian leadership at
the Pentagon why are we putting out
these videos on the proper use of
pronouns we should be worried about the
Chinese wanting to blow up our aircraft
carriers we should be worried about
their Hypersonic weapons we should be
worried about the threat of global
Terror which still exists we should
worry about the 80-something people on
the terror watch list that have been
apprehended at the southern border over
the last year a historic number and
those are the ones we caught usually if
you're on the terror watch list you
don't turn yourself in yeah well Senator
we are watching this race very closely
you have a decent lead but as you said
nothing can be taken for granted in
Florida or anywhere any state in the
country we wish you the best of luck out
there thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else